Did you see the clip that uh, um, uh,
Crooklyn from a Kirkland on,
on Twitter put up of I'm the owner of
bare knuckle boxing saying that a fighter
didn't fight hard enough.
Yeah, I saw that. Yeah. I um,
and, and, and he was proud of these.
Like this is the way we do it.
See if you can find her tweet.
Yeah. This is the way we do it.
This is what you could expect.
Yeah. That was ridiculous.
You just going to dock a guys
pay. Yeah. So she's getting,
he took 50% of his money
cause it didn't meet. Yeah.
Cause it didn't meet his
standards. Yeah. I just,
I'm one when he said did the crowd
chair as something that get done. Yeah,
I think so. I hope not. I'd hate to
see that some of the crowd gets here.
I said to the president,
I'll go up bare knuckle fighting champion.
This is Mr. David Rico phone man. He
looks like he's on coke. Look at them.
At least
looking at both of you guys having fun.
The make some noise.
[inaudible]
no fighting championship.
It's a brand new sport.
Nupur new company and we're here for
action and we want action and we demand
action from the fighter.
Mm.
We didn't get accident that last bite
cause rusty Crowder, one of the run,
therefore he's given half this Perth
to Reggie Barnett. Make some noise,
Biloxi. This is how we do it. At bare
knuckle, you fight or you don't get paid.
That's not good.
It's not good that he thinks that Zombie
Prophet wrote this can't be legal.
It was. See what Stephie
Hayes wrote, uh, Crooklyn MMA.
Wonder how that works. So like, okay.
[inaudible] she wrote what the
actual fuck is this hillbilly halted?
Ah, yeah. I concur.
What in the actual fuck is that hillbilly
bullshit? No pride. They used to dark,
right? The yellow card was a, yeah. A
yellow card is a penalty for being boring.
Most of them were. Yeah. And
sometimes irresponsibly. I,
I've watched some of those yellow
cards. I'm like, you crazy. You crazy.
Take that back. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He gave the guy a yellow car.
He can't fight the harder. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. We can't engage.
He's going to get lit up.
And these these moments we have to
try to figure out what the fuck to do.
You're on the outside, you're trying to
figure out how to get in. Right, right.
Well, and you get in and
then the referees, I caught
fight fight and you're like,
but in Asia at some of the,
like some of them as I used to work
a lot at this Korean show and they've
changed. They're figuring out their
style. But man, when I first got there,
they're like, um, so there's a yellow
card. Any backward step, a backstep,
any backstep you should, we move on
to take to give you a little card.
And I was like, Leo Machida would never
make any money. That's what I'm saying.
I don't know if I can do with that.
I don't think that's,
I mean you invited me over
here for a reason. I'm, I'm,
I'm just going to do what I
do and hope you bring me back,
but I don't know if I can do that.
Yeah. Good for you. Yeah. Do,
do you ever go to a place and the
commissions or a promoter will tell you,
hey, fights, go to the ground.
I want you to give it just a couple
of seconds and stand them up.
I go places and people telling me
what to do all the time. Really.
And I'm not gonna do it cause
people in the end of the day,
no one's gonna know that you told me to
do it. It's going to be me doing it 100%.
So yes. Yeah. So I'm gonna um,
yeah, I can't, I can't. Um,
yeah, basically. So glad you just said
it that way too. Cause that's, that's,
people need to get that in their head
because I know that sometimes people do
get affected by whether they want to
please a promoter or please a crowd or,
and they're not doing the right thing.
It's such a tremendous responsibility.
Yeah. You're going to be a bit,
you're the one who's going to be a,
for some of those choices, you
know, those choices that they made,
they're making those choices with
your name, so yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Like the backstep key,
Kevin Johnson answering the guy.
But this is a tweet from the bare
knuckle FC. Okay. Kevin Johnson,
no money was taken from any fighters.
That statement did exactly
what it's supposed to,
we're supposed didn't say to suppose and
lit a fire under every single fighters
ass from that point on giving you one
of the greatest fights you'll ever see.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Those guys fought that way because that's
who the fuck they are. Right, right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. No,
there's no had nothing to do with that.
Jason Knight and autumn low off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You can't,
you can't claim credit for a hint clearer
for Jason Knight doing what he did on
the lowball fuck Outta here.
They would fight that way in
a fucking Walmart parking lot.
That's how those guys would fight every
time they fight their case and night.
Both those dudes are,
and both those Luther's so tough.
Jason Knight has my favorite nickname.
Hick Diaz. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's like
a bad mother fucker. Yeah. Uh,
he's a bad motherfucker that, but it
was tough looking at their faces, man.
After the fight, I was like, man, I
might have to rethink my position on,
on bare knuckle fights. Look at
their faces afterwards. Yeah.
I mean that is crazy. You know,
it's a lifetime of cuts. Yeah.
All over the phone I'm looking at is,
is right under his nose cocktail.
Crazy cut man. He stitched, stitched
the fuck up all over the place.
That is rough man.
His whole face got lacerated.
I mean that is a lot
of cuts. Yeah. It's a,
that's more like a Moyie Thai fight
and it really makes you think,
but I can't, I'm, that's gotta be the
most brutal. Right. More time. Yeah,
I believe so. [inaudible]
type bare knuckle would be
like, what do they call it?
Left way where they just stay,
they kind of like wrap the hands up in a
a hand wrap. Yeah. It's up bare knuckle.
But it's um,
I think a bare,
bare knuckled Moitai would be the hardest.
But the thing,
what my argument was always,
and it still remains this,
that if you're not going
to pad anything else,
like you're not going to pad the shins,
who not going to bad the knees or the
elbows. Why you padding the knuckles,
you're just giving people a false sense
of security in terms of what is actually
effective.
We don't want,
we don't want to practice something that
doesn't really work if you don't have
gloves on. Right. I mean, if
every time you punch someone,
you don't have gloves on,
your hand would break. We would do
okay. We clearly can't punch people.
It's stupid. You gotta use elbows and
knees and you got to do something. Right.
Right,
right.
So in order to fight with your
knuckles as much as UFC fighters do,
you pat everything you
pad that you put raps,
you put padding over at boxing is like,
it's a different world.
As soon as you take gloves off,
Punches get in that you can't block,
it's it's way more consequence.
Lot more cuts.
But at least now we know
what actually works. Right.
I see. Interesting. I wasn't thinking
about it from that point of view.
He has that has given people, people are
thinking that, uh, yeah, you're right.
Like people think that
boxing will be four in May,
may or thing was the most effective
way of doing things. Yeah.
But then when you a MMA as
a whole different from the
size of the boxing glove,
oh,
the techniques you can do and what you
can't do and what's gonna work and what's
not gonna work. Yeah. It's,
it's supposed to be the sport of fighting
and you basically brought it down to a
raw form,
but you're still covering the knuckles
and patting the knuckles just because of
perception and see the
problem with that guy,
this bare knuckle got boxing guy when he
says some stupid shit like that is that
it reinforces what people
don't like about combat sports.
What people don't like about
the idea of bare knuckle boxing.
That it's brutal and it's just there for
chaos and write, write, write, write.
We come for action. We're
here to see action that guys
think out about MMA. Yeah.
And, and I don't think that, um,
I don't think that a MMA athletes,
I think a MMA athletes I think
are the most honorable and,
uh, well behaved. And, you
know, not because of fear,
anything because of what the sport is.